foreign
JavaScript is an essential part of
building Dynamic web applications it's
versatile and can be used to create
interactive user interfaces web-based
games data visualizations and so much
more today I'm going to show you how you
can quickly use a jumpstart solution to
quickly build a JavaScript Dynamic web
app on Google Cloud
JavaScript is one of the most popular
programming languages because it runs
everywhere enables development of
event-driven applications that Empower
Rich interactivity that respond to user
input and other web components and you
can use a single language to talk to
databases generate Dynamic content or
create interactive user experiences but
implementing a web app is much more than
choosing a language in a framework you
need a strategic architecture that
provides scalable web servers serves
Dynamic data from a database and static
assets from storage and you can't forget
about security you need to encrypt
sensitive configurations and data and
enforce a model of least privilege
between Services once you choose a cloud
serverless platform that handles scaling
you still need to decide on and set up
database and storage options based on
the characteristics of your application
identify configurations and data that
are sensitive and choose how you will
store these secrets and finally you need
to make sure that all these separate
components are configured and integrated
sure you can set up a cloud environment
yourself including compute a database
server web server CI CD security and
networking but you want to spend your
time working on your application and not
the underlying infrastructure
there are ways to ease the burden of
creating resources in the cloud like
infrastructure as code tools but we want
to help you stay focused on what you
care about the development of your
application for your users Google Cloud
however has a jumpstart solution where
you can deploy one of the most popular
Dynamic web application Stacks in the
cloud in just a few steps and in minutes
you'll Walk Away Learning how a
JavaScript Dynamic web app can run on
Google Cloud you'll see how Google Cloud
products work together to run a sample
app using Google Cloud's serverless
container platform manage database
service secret management CI CD tooling
and cloud storage
you'll also get learning resources for
updating the deployed application and
monitoring your application during run
time
this jumpstart solution lets you deploy
a JavaScript web app and all its
supporting infrastructure
it's a sample developer Journey web
application that gives developers a fun
user interface for exploring a simple
maze to find and collect resources that
provide technical tips once the solution
is deployed the architecture includes
the following components
users interact with the app by
connecting via URL Cloud CDN serves
cached assets if available
if not the request is routed to Cloud
load balancing which is a fully managed
and globally scalable https TCP SSL and
UDP load balancer for static assets
Cloud load balancing pulls from a cloud
storage bucket which is object storage
for dynamic resources Cloud load
balancing directs requests to Cloud run
the web service uses next.js and is
hosted on cloud run a fully managed
service that lets you build and deploy
serverless containerized apps it lets
you run containers to handle incoming
requests so you can focus on the logic
of your code sensitive values are
provided to Cloud run using environment
variables stored in secret manager
secret manager is a Secure Storage
platform for managing API Keys passwords
certificates and other sensitive data
Cloud run queries user data from
firestore which is a nosql database
backend for the JavaScript application
the jumpstart solution lets you deploy
the solution with all the resources
required
once you hit deploy Google Cloud will
automatically create and configure all
the cloud resources needed to run this
app and deploy the application code
once it's deployed you can access the
web app like a user and Explorer or like
an administrator and explore the
deployment which consists of multiple
primary services that have been
integrated into a single Google Cloud
project
then you can use our learning resources
and interactive tutorials to explore how
the application is built
for those of you who want to customize
the solution or update the client server
application on cloud run check out the
interactive tutorial
explore the solution backend check out
an interactive tutorial that lets you
explore a dynamic JavaScript web app to
learn more about your solution
deployment
and finally to troubleshoot common
errors check out the solution guide
keep in mind this jumpstart JavaScript
Dynamic web app solution gives you a
great way to explore the capabilities of
Google cloud and isn't intended to be
used as is for production environments
you can learn a way to deploy Dynamic
web apps on Google Cloud using products
that are modular secure and scalable
check out the links below to try this
jumpstart Solution on your own
[Music]